qué significan los componentes de
vectores las componentes de vectores son
una forma de descomponer en piezas
perpendiculares los vectores por
conveniencia típicamente elegimos las
partes del vector que van en las
direcciones xy en otras palabras para
encontrar la componente vertical de este
vector total conociendo este ángulo ya
que esta componente vertical es opuesta
al ángulo podemos escribir esta
componente vertical como la magnitud del
componente total por el seno del ángulo
y ya que esta componente horizontal es
adyacente a el ángulo la podemos
describir como la magnitud del vector
total por el coseno de este ángulo y si
ahora nos dieran este ángulo para
determinar la componente vertical de
este vector total ya que esta componente
vertical se encuentra adyacente a este
ángulo la vamos a encontrar como la
magnitud del vector total por el coseno
de este ángulo y si queremos encontrar
esta componente horizontal como esta
componente es opuesta al ángulo la vamos
a encontrar multiplicando la magnitud
del vector total por el seno del ángulo
así que recuerden para encontrar el lado
opuesto
vamos a usar seno
y si queremos encontrar el lado
adyacente vamos a usar el coseno como
luce un ejemplo que involucra a las
componentes de vectores digamos que
tenemos esta pregunta y queremos
determinar las componentes xy del vector
velocidad que se muestra ya que la
componente horizontal es adyacente al
ángulo que nos están dando vamos a
describir la componente horizontal como
la magnitud del componente total 20
metros por segundo multiplicado por el
seno de 60 grados lo que nos da 10
metros por segundo y ya que la
componente vertical es opuesta a este
ángulo la vamos a encontrar como la
magnitud del vector total 20 metros por
segundo
multiplicado ahora por el seno del
ángulo que es de 60 grados lo que nos da
17.3 metros por segundo pero como este
componente vertical va hacia abajo
técnicamente esta componente vertical
será de menos 17.3 metros por segundo
así que usamos ceros y cosenos para
encontrar la magnitud de las componentes
nosotros debemos agregar los signos
negativos de acuerdo a la dirección de
estas componentes si el vector apunta
hacia la derecha
su componente horizontal será positiva
si el vector apunta hacia la izquierda
su componente horizontal será negativa
si el vector apunta hacia arriba su
componente vertical será positiva y si
el vector apunta hacia abajo su
componente vertical será negativa que
significa la suma de vectores del
extremo al origen es una forma gráfica
de sumar o restar vectores entre sí y
esto funciona colocando el origen del
siguiente vector en el extremo o punta
del vector anterior y ya que hacemos
esto para todos nuestros vectores
dibujamos el vector total desde el
primer origen hasta el último extremo o
punta en otras palabras si estamos
sumando los vectores a b y c voy a
colocar el origen del vector b en la
punta del vector a y también voy a
colocar el origen del vector c en la
punta o extremo del b
y ya que terminamos voy a dibujar el
vector total poniendo su origen desde el
primer origen y su extremo en el último
extremo que dibuje y este vector total
representa la suma de los vectores a b y
c y si quieren restar vectores pueden
usar este método simplemente van a
invertir este vector en otras palabras
si tienen un vector b y le quieren
restar el vector a en lugar de pensar en
esto como en restar el vector a piense
en sumar el vector menos a y encontramos
el vector menos a colocando su extremo o
su punta en el otro lado del vector y
como luce un problema que involucra a la
suma de vectores del extremo al origen
imaginen que tenemos esta pregunta y
estos cuatro vectores y nos preguntan
cuál es la dirección de la suma de todos
los vectores usamos la suma de vectores
de origen apunta tomamos el vector y
manteniendo su dirección no lo podemos
rotar ni cambiar su tamaño
este le vamos a sumar el vector vez lo
hago tomando este vector de y colocando
su origen en la punta del vector a ahora
sumamos el vector ce y lo hacemos
tomando su origen y colocándolo en el
extremo del vector b hacemos lo mismo
con el vector d lo tomamos y colocamos
su origen en el extremo o punta del
vector ce y ya que colocamos así todos
nuestros vectores
nuestro vector total lo vamos a dibujar
desde el primer origen hasta la punta
del último vector que sumamos lo que
significa que esta es la dirección y
magnitud del vector suma total del
vector total que es la suma del vector a
b c + d
una forma más matemática de sumar o
restar vectores es simplemente sumar o
restar sus componentes individuales para
encontrar el vector total a más b
en lugar de graficar los y colocarlos de
origen apunta podemos encontrar las
componentes horizontales y verticales
por separado sumando las componentes
verticales y horizontales de los
vectores individuales en otras palabras
para encontrar la componente horizontal
total del vector a más b puedo tomar la
componente horizontal de a que es menos
20 y sumar la con la componente
horizontal de b que es menos 5 lo que me
da menos 25 y para encontrar la
componente vertical total de esta suma
de vectores voy a sumar la componente
vertical de a que es menos 15 con la
componente vertical de b que es 10 lo
que me da menos 5 esta técnica nos
permite encontrar rápidamente cuáles son
las componentes de este vector total y
nuevamente si necesitamos restar
vectores simplemente lo que hacemos
es sumar las componentes con la
excepción de que las componentes de un
vector negativo se van a multiplicar por
menos 1 en otras palabras si el vector a
tiene componentes de menos 20 y menos 15
el vector menos a va a tener componentes
de 20 positivo y 15 positivo como luce
un ejemplo que involucra a la suma de
componentes de vectores digamos que
tenemos esta pregunta y tenemos a estos
vectores a y b y queremos conocer las
componentes del vector total además ver
para encontrar la componente horizontal
de este vector total además ve vamos a
sumar la componente horizontal de a es 4
más la componente horizontal de b que es
menos 1 lo que me da una componente
horizontal total de más 3 hacemos lo
mismo para la componente vertical
sumamos la componente de a más la
componente de b que es de 5 más menos 4
lo que me da 1 positivo
ya que la componente horizontal total de
mi vector es positiva sé que va a
apuntar hacia la derecha tres unidades y
ya que la componente vertical de mi
vector total es positiva va a apuntar
hacia arriba una unidad lo que significa
que mi vector total a + b va a apuntar
una unidad hacia arriba y tres unidades
a la derecha como trabajamos con
problemas que involucran la cinemática 2
de la cinemática en dos dimensiones o de
proyectiles describen los objetos que
vuelan a través del aire en ángulos para
estos objetos si no hay nada más que
esté actuando sobre ellos a excepción de
la gravedad su aceleración vertical será
igual a menos 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y no tendrá ninguna aceleración
horizontal ya que la gravedad no empuja
hacia los lados también el
comportamiento de las velocidades y las
aceleraciones de x
es independiente lo que significa que
usaremos ecuaciones diferentes para
determinar la dirección vertical de la
dirección
ya que la aceleración vertical es
constante
podemos usar las fórmulas cinemáticas
para encontrar las cantidades en la
dirección vertical pero solo podemos
usar cantidades verticales en estas
ecuaciones de forma similar ya que la
aceleración es cero en la dirección
horizontal podemos usar la fórmula de la
distancia como la velocidad por el
tiempo para relacionar las cantidades en
la dirección x pero solo debemos usar
cantidades horizontales en esta ecuación
en otras palabras conforme un proyectil
está volando ya que no hay una
aceleración horizontal
el componente horizontal de la velocidad
va a ser el mismo para todo el recorrido
lo que significa que la tasa a la que se
mueve este proyectil en la dirección x
nunca va a cambiar pero ya que si hay
aceleración en la dirección vertical el
componente vertical de la velocidad va a
hacerse cada vez más pequeño conforme
sube hasta que alcanza la cima lo que
significa que la rapidez total del
proyectil va aa
disminuir también conforme se acerca a
la cima y en la cima será cero nuestro
componente vertical de la velocidad ya
que el proyectil no se está moviendo
hacia arriba o hacia abajo en ese
momento y conforme baja el componente
vertical de la velocidad de este
proyectil se va a estar haciendo cada
vez más negativo por lo que la velocidad
de este proyectil va a aumentar cada vez
más conforme baja tengan en mente que
durante todo este recorrido la
aceleración vertical va a ser la misma
- 9.8 durante todo este trayecto
conforme sube cuando llega a la cima y
conforme va bajando esta aceleración
nunca cambia como luce un ejemplo que
involucra a la cinemática en dos
dimensiones digamos que una albóndiga
rueda horizontalmente en la mesa a una
altura h con una rapidez ve y queremos
saber qué tan lejos llegará
horizontalmente la albóndiga antes de
caer al suelo y lo primero que debemos
hacer es dibujar un diagrama
la altura de la mesa es h la rapidez
inicial de la albóndiga es b y queremos
saber qué tan lejos llegará
horizontalmente antes de caer al suelo
pero vean que este problema es simbólico
no nos están dando ningún número así que
tendremos que dar la respuesta en
términos de las constantes fundamentales
y las cantidades dadas las cantidades
dadas son h y b y las constantes
fundamentales son cosas como g minúscula
así que esta cantidad que queremos
encontrar es el desplazamiento
horizontal que será la rapidez en la
dirección horizontal multiplicada por el
tiempo que estuvo en el aire recuerden
que la rapidez en la dirección
horizontal va a permanecer constante
todo el trayecto así que esta vez va a
ser la misma durante todo este trayecto
así que podemos sustituir be en lugar de
la rapidez pero no conozco cuál será el
tiempo que esté en el aire y para saber
este dato vamos a usar otra ecuación
pero ahora en la dirección vertical el
desplazamiento vertical no va
ser h va a ser menos h ya que la
albóndiga está cayendo va hacia abajo y
la velocidad inicial en la dirección
vertical no será ver va a hacer 0 ya que
esta albóndiga no tiene velocidad
vertical ni hacia arriba ni hacia abajo
al menos en el instante justo cuando
deja la mesa solo tiene velocidad
horizontal la aceleración es menos 9.8
pero como nos están pidiendo que esto
sea simbólico vamos a escribirlo en
términos de constantes fundamentales así
que aquí pondremos menos g despejamos
usted y nos queda la raíz cuadrada de 2
h / g lo que ahora podemos sustituir acá
para encontrar el desplazamiento
horizontal de esta albóndiga justo antes
de tocar el suelo algo que
definitivamente necesitan conocer para
hacer este examen es gráficas datos para
que queden lineales ya que a veces
cuando gráficas datos resultan en una
gráfica que no es lineal es decir no es
una línea y cuando no tenemos una
gráfica línea
y es difícil encontrar la pendiente en
una gráfica curva sin embargo pueden
forzar sus datos para que queden
lineales si escriben la expresión queda
la relación de sus datos con la forma de
una línea recta la forma de una línea
recta es igual a m por x + b que es el
eje vertical x es el eje horizontal m es
la pendiente y b será la intercepción en
ye en otras palabras si tenemos la
expresión p igual a un medio por d
cuadrada si gráfica mos p contra d
tendremos una parábola lo que significa
que tendremos problemas ya que encontrar
la pendiente de una parábola es bastante
difícil pero si en lugar de esto
elegimos graficar p contra d cuadrada
tendremos una línea recta ya que ahora
tendremos a p como nuestro eje vertical
y a de cuadrada como nuestro eje
horizontal y la pendiente que es lo que
está multiplicando a lo que nosotros
llamamos x es una constante
significa que no está pendiente va a ser
constante y esto nos permite predecir
cuál será la pendiente al menos cuando
gráfica mos p contra de cuadrada ya que
la pendiente siempre va a ser aquello
que esté multiplicando a nuestro eje
horizontal así que la pendiente en este
caso siempre va a ser un medio en otras
palabras si forzamos nuestra expresión a
que tenga la forma de una línea recta no
solamente tendremos una gráfica lineal
sino que también podremos predecir cuál
será la pendiente al ver aquello que
está multiplicando lo que sea que
nosotros determinamos como x pero muchas
personas encuentran esto confuso y
extraño así que veamos un ejemplo que
involucre la gráfica de datos para que
queden lineales digamos que nos dan esta
pregunta donde ruedas una esfera varias
veces sobre una mesa con una rapidez
variable ve y mides qué tan lejos llegó
horizontalmente delta x antes de caer al
suelo si la mesa está fija y tiene una
altura h
graficar para determinar el valor
experimental de la magnitud de la
aceleración debida a la gravedad g así
que cambiamos la rapidez con la que
empujamos esta esfera y medimos qué tan
lejos llegó esta esfera horizontalmente
así que estas son las cantidades que
están variando por lo que estas
variables serán las que usaremos para
nuestra equis y nuestra y pero para
saber qué graficar debemos encontrar una
relación que involucre estas dos
variables de manera que podamos poner
esta relación con la forma de una línea
en la sección anterior de cinemática 2d
vimos justamente la fórmula de que tanto
se desplaza una bola que está rodando
sobre una mesa en términos de la altura
de la mesa y la aceleración debida a la
gravedad así que esta es la fórmula que
relaciona qué tan rápido se mueve la
esfera o la bola y qué distancia
recorren horizontalmente y necesitamos
poner esto en la forma de una línea
recta
más fácil es hacer que este lado
izquierdo sea nuestro eje vertical así
que la cantidad de iu en nuestro eje
vertical va a ser el desplazamiento
horizontal lo que está bien ya que delta
x es una de las cosas que están variando
en nuestros datos de forma similar la
otra cantidad que vamos a graficar en
nuestro eje horizontal va a ser b así
que llamaremos a de x así que el eje
horizontal va a ser b y poder hacer esto
ya que esto es b si esto hubiera sido b
cuadrada aquí en el eje horizontal
tendría que poner b cuadrada y si esto
hubiera sido la raíz cuadrada de b en el
eje horizontal tendría que poner raíz
cuadrada de b pero como aquí tenemos
simplemente ven pues es lo que pongo en
el eje horizontal y para encontrar lo
que representa nuestra pendiente tenemos
que igual a m por x así que todo aquello
que multiplique a lo que nosotros
llamamos x será la pendiente y la forma
en la que está escrita aquí la m está
multiplicando a la x
del lado derecho pero no importa ya que
m x x es lo mismo que x por m lo que
significa que todo este término la raíz
cuadrada de 2 h / g es nuestra pendiente
en otras palabras tendremos una gráfica
lineal y el número que encontraremos
para la pendiente será igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 2 por h / g y ya que no
tenemos agregado un término b aquí no
tendremos una intercepción en g así que
no nos preocupamos por esto y cómo vamos
a determinar el valor experimental de la
magnitud de la aceleración debida a g
tomamos nuestros datos los gráfica moss
ponemos nuestra gráfica lineal sobre
estos datos y vamos a usar los puntos
sobre nuestra línea para encontrar la
pendiente tomamos el desplazamiento
vertical y lo dividimos entre el
desplazamiento horizontal y este
desplazamiento vertical entre el
desplazamiento horizontal nos va a dar
la pendiente y sabemos que ese número va
a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de 2 por
h / g
así que conocemos este número de la
pendiente
y sabemos que la mesa tiene una altura
fija h y la única interrogante es g que
ahora podemos despejar